superman lewis is back uh you're you're
moving this week so it's last week in
the office that's that's why it's kind
of plain background right now i clearly
worked hard to try to supplement it
guys
full length watch long as we sing it
with superman and lois or over at our
patreon page saying so i'll become super
sexy rejects by checking everything we
gotta offer over there also if you can't
do that leave a like like that button
laser that button punch trip tonight
whatever some pun intended button
subscribe and click the notification
while you're notified when our next
reaction for superman lost is up here on
the channel
and also uh boys are prepper i think
they're editing pretty hard to make sure
we get this up to you so
thanks yeah all right let's do it
leave lana for me
how did people not put this together see
who they want to see
oh clark where'd you come from
if you had powers
since we were kids
puppet power that's how you punch me
through that wall
that's why he left to become
superman why didn't you come back for me
i did
you were with kyle
yeah but you're superman why didn't you
laser kyle in the head i would have left
kyle
if i knew you were superman
i gotta go
that did not go as well as he hoped
we knew she would be hurt say no should
be that hurt
i kind of knew
so let me just reach out and i'm gonna
try to smooth things over for you two i
will see if i can try to figure out what
halley's next move is after you drop the
boys off of course so that is the plot
of today's episode
strapping
besides this guy was literally puffing
more of that stuff than i was maybe but
i didn't get the whole season cancelled
so what what do you think any of this
matters you think football matters think
baseball matters i think even high
school matters all of it's meaningless
this is some system bro
maybe you shouldn't be here
where do you want to go
you're gonna skip on your first day back
starting to lose track of which one to
use the bizarro version
there's always another way i don't think
you really believe that you're the hero
right now also did superman just lie to
me
mom
lana
birth to lana people must feel so
freaking stupid when they learn the
truth
how did i how did i not see this
oh god i really can't talk important
call oh just my new assistant wondering
where i am
gotta go
see that she was tempted to tell him
we gotta kill her
and i wanna give you the chance to make
up for some of the hurt you've caused
help me save your world maybe if my dad
had ever
talked to me the way you are i know
i'd be on your side
but he didn't and i got
daddy
[Laughter]
you have no idea
ally's a god the people on my earth are
gonna merge with the people on your
earth
there's absolutely nothing you can do to
stop it
you weren't spanked enough as a boy
your dad should have been harsher with
you
you want to destroy the portal
a controlled explosion with an
ultrasound
you need to concentrate on this one he's
right we do what we can with the
information we have
we save our own the last time the two of
you came up with a plan to do that
it was by killing me
mm-hmm
there's always another way
and we're going to find one
clark clark clark kent
[Laughter]
i don't blame him for not telling me the
truth back then it hurts
but i can't be mad about it are you sure
cause you seem kind of mad i'm mad at
you
when my marriage was falling apart i
called you and this whole time you've
been keeping this huge secret from me it
wasn't my secret to share our entire
friendship was built on a lie i mean
there's a lie involved
and the worst part about it
is that you've made me a liar too
as mayor i'm going to tell everyone i
think it's important to blame women
blame all women
hashtag
yes
don't you feel like our parents still
view us all as little kids all the time
yeah sometimes
let's do something about it
adult suits
you built your own kill suit
it looks so female
after you're running with your
look-alike i thought you might need it
more than i do
it should prevent any more
non-consensual merging
that's i mean this is the coolest
present i've ever gotten yeah we have
the ps5
in order to power the suit i still need
the key component but i can't get it by
myself
i need your help digging it out okay
where to
the wild west mines absolutely
boy howdy
did you meet my wife
would you believe me if i told you that
you helped save my son's life
of course i would in any other world
brother you and i are the best of
friends
nothing i do will ever be enough
because it's not you i have to convince
is it
lana
lois
guess who lana hates more than you
kyle no
kyle
makes no sense and it's just another
classic example of women holding each
other to higher standards and we hold
men no i don't i don't yeah that's why
we believe you guys
come on get with the program
no
hello lois
hello is how the hell did you arrange
this question yes jesus
and i have time to stop for flowers i've
come to try and make amends well which
part did you want me to forgive first
how you kidnapped my son or how you
tried to eradicate all of humanity lois
who was it when you rewrote my article
on the daily planet i told you you
should bring that up
[Laughter]
such a long way
but i was convinced that if i fulfilled
his dreams then
my own might also come true that i may
one day be reunited with my brother i
had no idea
when he chose you over me
i got angry wow is everything my fault
today
[Laughter]
but you can't trust me lois when i tell
you i will never hurt anyone
you love again it's john henry and your
dad we've got to get you out of here
you're not going anywhere
oh oh i apologize to a lot more people
the apology door i'm asking you to trust
me
he is a sociopath there's no need for
name-calling
[Laughter]
ally is gonna get to lucy before we do
and you know it dad so just figure this
out i have
something i have to do
this is secondary on my lips yes i need
a suffix with water
yeah buddy
this morning your mama was just uh just
off she didn't go for like a six hour
walk yesterday so
oh then i wouldn't be too worried i mean
a worry is a wish for something you
don't want i'm not in therapy
huh
a worry is a wish for something you
don't want that's a great scene let me
get that textured word i'm gonna forget
that
no
what was i supposed to remember
jesus you guys sure do make me in smart
cool
i have an idea
screw smart i'd rather have powers
knowledge is power jonathan
right
i was afraid this would happen
sarah ever sees you do that you guys are
definitely getting back together
let's go do it now yeah
where's the bag of xk
i mean jordan could probably get back in
there
these two should be more than enough
well then
no time like the present
i don't trust him
i'm sorry i don't
i'm sorry everyone
well you got enough here for an entire
album
i mean that's kind of the goal right so
give it
thank you my dad's a truck
but he got me a car
this walk
that she went on you think that she was
with someone was it a sex walk
upright walk or a horizontal block
is your mama dating someone already i
don't know i have no idea
if you want to talk to mom about her
personal life then do it
you just keep writing your music okay
it's really good thank you
can't put your divorce on your kids man
hey tonya it's uh
it's kyle
no listen can you give me a call when
you get a chance did you go walk in with
lana listen i know it's going to take a
lot of time to earn back your trust but
i want to start now let's start with
jordan
turns out he takes after his dad
you put him around my daughter
you put her in harm's leg
[Music]
it's working
don't turn your head morgan come on
wait what the hell just happened
oh damn it
i'm taking you back
what's mine
whoa
what the [ __ ] so that's what the coming
hole looks like i can't have that now
can we
hello
clark do something yeah come on what did
you just do today
john she's got superman you need to
hurry
lock on target i told you superman
we would become
good [ __ ] john henry arms i don't have
much left brother
rather do i
no
make it quick i could do this all day
give it everything you got
come on
put it on the volcano
tom
ah
and she was feeding off my energy to
make herself stronger glitch so now we
have an enemy who can steal superman's
powers and potentially use them against
us how the hell do we defeat something
like that castle her on twitter yes
that's the first step
discredit her entirely
honey i'm not dating anyone
so then what is it
you have been acting kind of weird
clunker superman jorge's powers jonathan
lomas lied to me for years and years
i just learned something that's kind of
a big deal and i want to share it with
you
sarah sniper wolf just posted a new
video come watch with us hey she makes
great videos go follow sniper she
doesn't react to super bad at lois
though yeah what
missed out
there is an internship available in my
office and i know that you're looking to
beef up your college resume so i figure
nepotism do you mind if i
if i think about it oh absolutely
is that what lois told her that's right
you need to bring sarah on as an intern
hey can we talk somewhere
in private
we're gonna tell you everything now
everything everything everything
more than you ever wanted to do
we're just making you aware as the
situation unfolds is smallville in
danger honestly we can't be sure of
anything as long as ally's still out
there yes
but i also can't have you in my life
right now not just mine but my kids
i don't want to feel like i'm lying to
them every time our families are
together and i think it would be easier
for everyone if we just made a clean
break
wow
damn
that was unexpected yeah i know i'm
pretty mature for my age but you know
i'm not actually 21 right
yeah i'm aware
oh my goodness yeah
it's over mike knight
why not launch the next big thing right
here you're smaller sad i'm not the next
big thing
oh but that's the
goal oh [ __ ]
jamie spears what is going on
ashley simpson knows
i'm reaching for the stars and hoping
that the sky won't fall
[Music]
then it's over what
what why didn't we go back
away from that
no from one prison to the next you a new
savior
whoa
no no no no no no no no no no
oh
no
wowie that is a dead toro
tall don't be dead dude she's obsessed
with human centipeding these worlds man
[Laughter]
together sick [ __ ]
that's the future
we did not watch the extended version so
i don't know if uh sarah plays her whole
song
there in the extended version i don't
even know if there's an extended version
out there's a whole 10 minute musical
sequence yeah half the bard left
it cut back so this needs
[Laughter]
wow mom sarah seems so believable
such a believable she seems like a lot
of teenage girls that uh
i know currently
that i spend time with regularly today
yeah
absolutely it reminds me of all my
teenage girl friends as well
very authentic
oh man when i was a teenager this is the
exact kind of girls i would hang out
with
[ __ ] friend zoning the greg oh
now we're at a million subscribers
now [ __ ]
crawling back
asking for a piece of the g train
yeah what now once
uh send them packing
[Laughter]
yes that was a surprise i was into that
i was really enjoying her her musical
number
which wouldn't cut away i know
anyway but the real meat of this episode
is lana
not being able to handle anything
because she's weak a man could handle
the secrets
that's right a man knows how to bottle
it up for years and not give a crap
yeah
yeah i know she
i respect that so that is a very dehuman
response
true at all
i guess i'd blame lana lois too
kind of
i guess speak it i i can sympathize with
that thing of like i guess you sought me
out to be friends and so i could see how
that would feel like almost like you're
making up for something
but it is it's
i don't know i mean
it's an unprecedented my man's planning
here i feel like
it's ultimately
she can't tell lana unless clark
gives the go ahead like unless clark is
also okay with it
yeah
i mean to me it almost
registers as such that
if you're going to take that view of
it's not mice it was my
i don't know she holds a secret she's
part of the secret keepers but she it's
ultimately
it's like the solution to that is just
to knock around like it's my secret to i
could tell everyone yeah
i gotta recover and endanger our family
who cares i i have every right to do
that
i mean and also it took her some time to
get adjusted to being in smallville you
know like that's a monumental secret and
they've only been there for like a year
or something right they haven't been
there that long yeah well and you wonder
too like how much does lois know about
lana and clark's past relationship and
all that stuff like there's i don't know
there's a lot of contributing factors
and it's also an unprecedented secret to
have to keep like you know not on the
president it happens more often than you
realize that's true especially in this
world
a lot of people got secret identities
being covered for
yeah yeah i mean it's like i like the
respect of the i like the response she
gave to lois at the same time but though
when i thought about it i was like i
don't know if i really agree with this
um that it's
lois's
i mean
hey guys it becomes an interesting thing
to me because i felt
part of me almost expected them to do a
thing with lana and i know there's not
as much time as this probably but to go
kind of like oh yeah this is a big
secret to have to keep and i can't just
tell everybody
you know and so maybe this is kind of a
tricky thing i respect yeah that it
comes down to like i don't want to be in
this position where i have to lie to
everybody close to me
and then be thinking about this every
time we all get together
so we need to spend some time apart like
i don't expect that to be a permanent
thing but but yeah i mean there are
multiple ways to look at it but i
appreciate that they
allow for that for that kind of a nuance
where you can sort of sit there and and
i think legitimately have your own
subjective response of what you would do
in lana's position i do respect what she
does at the end though
i admire that that's totally that's
totally reasonable i think
i mean if it was me
i'd be like tell me more oh my god
there's so many stories i could hear
oh my god you know like
i had a
i have friends who
i've known for a while
i mean years one of my friends i've
known for many many many many years
since we were children
and then um
one day she tells me she's pregnant
and
then i find out that
oh my god it's with this guy who she's
always been around
we always made fun of like ah that guy's
always so into her but he's not she's
not into him and apparently they're
dating for secret for like a year oh and
now they're married
and i went
wow impressive tell me more
not like why'd you keep this this was
our foundation of our friendship is a
lot like hell we worked together and we
were just trying to keep it on the down
low and i don't know they gave her their
reasonings and whatever and i was like
all right
that's cool it's kind of crazy
you just tell me something like that and
be like wow
granted
i know it's almost a one-to-one
comparison but it's ultimately not
i don't i think you could argue that it
is in some ways it is you know very
similar i think
very applicable to these circumstances
because knowing my friend changed all of
los angeles california for the
foreseeable future
and uh my entire life vastly changed
everything's recontextualized so many
times um i was in danger and i was
rescued and having had weird
supernatural
extraterrestrial experiences since
and if i had just known they were dating
that would have changed everything could
have avoided every step of the way
or just not fill up that loop i blamed
him for not telling me
as you should have like i get why she
didn't tell you but you have no excuse
bro i've been friends for a year
before
no matter how long your committed
relationship has perceived this
yeah man if you had every right
um
right
so
all right yeah i guess i don't blame
lana good for her
good for her something that's weird kyle
called up that x girl could just call
the bar directly
uh it's opened my head that hard to get
right
in smallmouth
with the amount of people there who
seemed to be kind of surprised that
anyone was playing music at first so i
already get uh
yeah it's hard to get a slot at that
empty open mic i played some strings
that this thing that's supposed to be
for walk-ups this is so obviously a
mislead yes to make you think like oh
calls acted out oh
dating he's gonna try to try to get some
action he's gonna make her jealous by
going back to the girl he cheated with
messed up man
messed up
and uh
to that's
i guess he's just here it was sincere
obviously the white wants a connection
with clark but yeah even though he
jumped ship at the end he's probably uh
shaw's a chance to be free but doesn't
mean he's gonna be hurting people he
didn't promise he wouldn't escape
he promised you wouldn't hurt them
anymore hurt the people they love
they could hurt anybody else in the
world anybody else yeah you don't know
this person
yeah what do you care
love really looks i'm hurting a bunch of
bizarro people now they're even further
removed from you guys in fact they've
tried to kill you multiple times who
cares
uh ally
nelly um watergate what's her name
matters to haley alston
[Music]
yes she's evil she's got cool uh you
know
cool monochromatic flash effects i don't
know why i just don't find them that
interesting
i you know she's
she's evil
i feel like uh she's more interesting
what it was
not what she's
since she merged yeah she is just evil
villain with great power and no more
nuance of character or scenes really of
her trying to exact some kind of
emotional based plan or anything
revealing about her character she's just
got power
she's got power
she wants to merge the worlds
that's all right cool and then you got
jonathan and jordan jordan saying mean
things and text messages apparently yeah
and we just leave huh hour later i'm
sorry i didn't mean it yeah ah hour
later you're such a [ __ ] all right
screw you you're probably on so much
texting
yes i don't know what i'd do without you
sarah come back to me
you [ __ ]
i should have never ever taken you to
the lake and let those camels
um
yeah
that but i like them bonnie and actually
hanging out and being friends like
natalie this episode i feel like that's
a cool role she serves with this little
future spin-off she got something else
to do aside from being like dad stop
except for build [ __ ] with the dad build
[ __ ] for the boys yeah
and have fun with that instead of being
like stop putting yourself in harm's way
yeah now it's like no jonathan come on
let's have some fun and put yourself in
harmony yeah come on let's go into
collapsing mine let's do this
uh but now there was something that
felt it was nice to just see them
hanging out like kids just hanging out
yeah and all like laughing and stuff and
yeah even though it's like a pretty big
secret they have from john henry it's
like yeah it's a nice little bonding
moment and it feels like
not like it's kind of like a little
scooby gang which is a nice uh you know
dynamic to throw in especially for now i
think especially for natalie's character
it actually feels more like uh aang
katara and saka you know what i mean i
know what you mean from naruto the curse
of their bangers
my favorite anime
yeah you guys know what i'm talking
about
like
jonathan saka
kataras
natalie yeah aang is georg he's oppa
that's right
i know characters
i think they uh which one is rock lee
[Laughter]
best boy
um
but
the [ __ ] yes what happened in the
show again you know there was a lot of
dealing with that secret there was a lot
of we got to blow up the pendant john
henry and sam being like ah supes you
gotta you can't trust that edge you
gotta take the harsh path and then clark
be like there's always another way and
then he and tyler henry irons uh fended
off her way better than those two yeah i
know that hammer charged right after her
and she managed to fend her off for a
few couple minutes there yeah she can't
zap his robo power yeah that's the key
john henry should just step in and save
the whole day this season
be like i did your work for you guys
you owe me he is the mvp in a lot of
ways
yeah he comes in just at the right
moment it's beautiful yeah and it's fun
to watch that tension i'm rooting for
tauro to be a good d i mean he he's
probably going to sacrifice something
yeah
i thought this was the episode
yeah i was like oh you're gonna die now
no
i thought that prediction should come
true in the last episode i don't want
him to be dead
i like him too much yeah he's like
he won't be really you won't be truly
dead hey that's a good call gee he is
just like locus locus locus yeah i
remember in thor
in the dark world when loki tried to
eradicate the world that's right
trying to transplant all the asgardian
spirits into the people of earth
and then thor was like brother
you can't
our mother would not like this
in frigga's name
oh
that's a good point they really are yeah
yeah it's just like thor which one i say
dark rule yeah yeah dark world it's the
best one according to phase four the
most important thor movie
to refer back to all right guys time for
a page
james stegens
welcome back james stegen good to see
you
how's it going man hey cutie what are
you doing so
uh judging the cw show
still smoking cigarettes
cigarettes and doors while talking to
people on facetime sitting next to a
blank wall with some blinds next to it
in the dark like a film noir guy still
not liking things as much as other
people like them still having hot takes
very succinctly
james good to see you man yeah thanks
for coming back was that you in the live
stream
it's a different james stegen dude
there's so many james stegen's it's one
of the most popular names in america
it's james stegens from another
dimension who's come back dude it's
bizarro stegens it's james snegetz
and
you know this version of james is very
just very uh a
anti-smoker
always wears a nicotine patch everywhere
he goes has perfect 20 20 eyesight
um
decorations all over his walls mexican
actually actually kept the name stegen's
yes
full-blown mexican jaime stegens
and uh he's also six foot ten mm-hmm in
fact you call him a completely different
name simon james yeah
it's just tall boy now you gave brother
you finished you passed you said pledge
a hundred dollars i think so
why why would you i don't know dude
what's what gives there's nothing we can
try to prove steve nothing we can do
i mean thank you well we'll take it oh
yeah but going to good use yeah right
now i'm gonna get in and out later
so many double doubles
all for the two of us
we still don't feel worthy of such a
contribution but thanks man especially
after so long
we make us feel loved well i feel like
he's making up for being away from
that's right you owe us
he thinks he has a bill to pay and he
was charged interest for late payments
i have several months of that five
dollars here to pick up on i better do
it all in one go
if i'm going to enjoy that much times
worth of content
[Music]
yeah this should be a thing where people
do a patreon or they just pay for a year
that's possible there is yes
i will do that for no creator
one lucky subscriber gets that annual
membership
we'll do it that way anyway james thanks
for being back man it's good to see your
name otherwise
i don't see your face
[Music]